pilas de bolsas de basura y desperdicios
llevan desde el jueves acumuladas en las
calles de beirut después de que las dos
principales compañías de recogida de
basura y limpieza de las calles blanco y
city bloom hayan parado sus servicios al
no haber llegado a un acuerdo con la
municipalidad de beirut sobre sus
contratos los trabajadores la mayoría
migrantes exigen mejores laborales y una
subida de sueldo por la grave
depreciación de la libra libanesa ya que
prácticamente no están cobrando nada la
crisis de la basura se suma a las
múltiples crisis que afronta el líbano
desde la recesión económica la falta de
electricidad la escasez de suministros
básicos de medicinas y la parálisis
política el gobierno del bono no se ha
reunido desde el mes de octubre después
de los graves incidentes del 14 de
octubre en beirut donde murieron seis
personas en enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes flo hezbollah y sus
rivales cristianos sobre el transcurso
de la investigación del puerto de beirut
los libaneses se preguntan si las
montañas de basura será la estampa
navideña que sus gobernantes dejarán
para estas fiestas